caught up on 5 26 on your Monday morning
so a cab driver test provides the latest
in that long spaces between cars
conversation a fellow named John writes
hey 50 years ago I tested to become a
cab driver and he says at my first
traffic light The Examiner told me I was
too close to the car in front said to
stop when you see the rear tires meet
the pavement to allow room to move but
he says when moving in traffic The
Examiner advised one car length for each
10 mile per hour of speed for reaction
time but he says that's nearly
impossible these days because at 60
miles an hour with six car lengths in
front of you
at least eight entitled
self-absorbed idiots will cut you off
and squeeze in John thanks for writing
keep those emails coming buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
join the revenue crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com